or in turn really problematic as well
it-it-it justifies what are called what
what public health officials in the
united states call targeted
interventions that means interventions
that target particular categories of the
population for more breastfeeding
advocacy and more more powerful
breastfeeding advocacy more coercive
breastfeeding advocacy so there is a
profound difference between the way
middle and upper class women in the
United States experience breastfeeding
advocacy for them it's primarily in the
form of overzealous nurses or lactation
consultants in hospitals and the
appropriate of people in their social
circles but for poor people the United
States has long had much more coercive
ways of influencing the behavior in
particular of women but women who are
poor and vulnerable so the United States
has a program called the special
supplemental nutrition program for women
infants and children it's called WIC for
short and in 2009 WIC introduced what it
calls the enhanced food package and the
enhanced food package provides different
kinds of benefits for women who are
breastfeeding than it does for women who
are formula feeding so women who are
breastfeeding or entitled to WIC for
twice as long as mothers who formula
feed breastfeeding mothers get more and
better food than formula feeding mothers
breastfeeding babies even get more and
better foods and formula feeding babies
and breastfeeding mothers are
prioritized for intake and registration
so WIC is not actually an entitlement
program WIC can run out WIC funds can
run out and in the event of shortfall
WIC counselors are advised to register
and to register mothers who are
breastfeeding over mothers who are
formula feeding so in in the extreme
event feeding your baby formula formula
can
actually exclude you from qualification
or eligibility to WIC for WIC completely
a couple of months ago the well-known
harvard law professor cass sunstein
published an op-ed in the new york times
about his nudge theory and he argued in
his New York Times op-ed that so-so
since he wrote the book nudge he
subsequently went out and produced a
data set looking at how much Americans
want to be nudged what how much the
support is for for nudging and what he
argued in the New York Times op-ed was
that most Americans support government
nudging toward better behavior so
depending on the particular question he
asked support was anywhere from sixty to
eighty five percent for nudging and to
me this is really interesting because I
feel like nudging raises all kinds of
really interesting questions when you
look at it through the lens of of
breastfeeding advocacy and the first
question might be what counts as a nudge
and who gets to decide what's a nudge
and what is actually more like a shove
and a kick and it occurs to me that what
WIC is doing by withholding food from
women who are already at nutritional
risk and babies at nutritional risk that
doesn't seem so much like a nudge to me
now as a matter of fact Cass Sunstein
doesn't study WIC and so I don't know if
he would think that was a nudge but I
think in the government WIC probably
thinks it's a nudge and I think it goes
too far at any rate it would certainly
make you think you need to think
carefully about what counts as a nudge
and then the second question that I
think breastfeeding advocacy this whole
story raises
should we worry when nudges don't just
target particular behaviors you know the
behavior of people sort of randomly
scattered across society but instead
these nudges consistently seem to target
particular categories of people and then
the third question and this is something
you know that we could actually get a
got a handle on if we if we could get a
hold of Sunstein's data is to look at
what are the demographic differences in
his data so is it the case that African
Americans are as inclined to accept or
endorse government nudges as white
Americans might be or is it the case the
poor people would accept them as much as
wealthy people might be and is it the
case the people would have a different
answer when their thinking is the
government maybe gonna nudge me or is
the government really going to nudge all
of those other people that are
surrounding me who have bad behavior but
I will not be nudged right so it raises
all of these questions about you know I
think it forces us or it ought to force
us it ought to convince us to sort of
look carefully at what are what really
are reasonable nudges to to embrace and
finally I want to close with another
thought that links back to this idea of
a public health issue since the 1970s or
so United States public health in the
United States has focused increasing
attention on individual behaviors as the
cause of bad health so first it was
smoking then it was unsafe sex and
around this time around the time that
this all started in 1975 the Chicago
Tribune offered the opinion that the
idea of preventive medicine was quote
faintly unamerican
because it means recognizing that the
enemy is us it's faintly unamerican
because it means recognizing the
the enemy is us and it occurred to me
that in fact the idea is profoundly
American it extends the Horatio Alger
story from wealth to health we all have
the potential to be healthy we just need
to work at it we need to exercise some
moral fortitude we need to pull
ourselves up by the bootstraps and we
will succeed at health so this is
privatizing responsibility for health
and I think that's one way another way
in which breastfeeding fits very
conveniently into an American health
paradigm that increasingly blames
individuals themselves for poor health
outcomes and for the soaring costs of
American health care but it's not just a
matter of blaming individuals at point I
was making before when we blame
individual lifestyle choices for the
crisis of American health care we're not
only blaming random unhealthy
individuals in our society we are
consistently blaming some category of
people so unsafe sex for example is
associated with gay men prostitutes and
IV drug users smoking is more prevalent
among people who are poor obesity is
more prevalent among people who are
African American and the failure to
breast feed of course is the failure of
women but not all women women who are
poor women who are african-american
women who are unmarried and women who
are young so a deal with breastfeeding
is basically that is practically perfect
in the sense that it serves so many
purposes in the United States today for
all kinds of people it stands as a
marker of who we are and what we believe
in for a fast-growing breastfeeding
accessory support and supplements market
it is a huge source of it is a source of
huge mostly untapped potential profit
the demographic and social distribution
of breast feeders Shores
many of the distant divisions and
hierarchies that have long characterized
American life and breastfeeding
privatizes responsibility for health
blaming mothers not only for infant
infections but for cardiovascular
disease high blood pressure obesity
diabetes asthma allergies pretty much
any condition that their children may
get over the course of an entire
lifetime and that my friends is the deal
with breastfeeding Thank You mala ton is
going to comment on my book it's a tough
act to follow but um I am really happy
to be back here at the new school above
all back here with my dear friend and
former colleague Courtney and talking
about her book lacta vism so first I
want to say that this book is vintage
Courtney it is brilliantly argued it has
her characteristic sardonic tone it's
often hilarious and I have really
enjoyed reading it now they're gonna be
three parts to my commentary I'm not
gonna speak for more than 10 or 15
minutes so don't worry I'm first gonna
talk about what I took is the strengths
of the book then I'll make a couple of
remarks about areas that where I thought
the book was ambivalent or needing some
improvement and finally I just want to
make two points about sort of the bigger
picture or the broader implications of
this book for how we think about gender
equality so first I think that the book
and she didn't mention all of it today
but the book does a real demolition job
of lacta vist extremists in a way that's
that that's reminiscent of Jenny Mann's
bridges book oh why we lost the e ra it
shows that kind of single-minded over
committed activists can end up
undermining their own cause because they
are so kind of intolerant and
ideological
the second thing is that it sort of
brilliantly analyzes and traces the
evolution of breastfeeding which means
breast baby into breast milk feeding
which she did talk about today via via
the pump right and she also calls out
the policymakers and the business
interests who would seemingly make
motherhood compatible with working via
pumping without any change to the
structural conditions or the policy
frameworks final uh not final but the
second to last point like kristin lucre
does in her brilliant book abortion in
the politics of motherhood courtney
shows the way that breastfeeding is just
the tip of the iceberg right so
breastfeeding is here but underneath the
water of the iceberg is a whole package
of agendas world views ideologies so
people are investing the humanly act of
breastfeeding with so much more than
just a way to feed children and I think
today she succeeded in mapping out what
those agendas and actors are and finally
on a personal note I think that this
book has succeeded in calling out people
including myself who have looked down on
and felt superior to other women who
aren't breastfeeding or not
breastfeeding as well and I am actually
grateful to Courtney for staying my hand
in that kind of behavior ok so what are
some of the ambivalences now Courtney
says sort of repeatedly through the book
that this is a book about lactam ism um
but she has a problem with lactam ISM
not with breastfeeding soul activism is
a social movement and a political
project breastfeeding is a humanly
practice that has sustained you know the
human race as long as we've been around
but at times in the book there is a
conflation or a slippage of lacta vism
and breastfeeding and I think that
perhaps is a
consequence of the slippage I'm not
gonna be so anal and go and like point
out the passages but we can do that
later um perhaps as a consequence of the
slippage at points Courtney has a
tendency to blame breastfeeding for a
series of social ills that are not
breastfeeding x' fault
so in political science terms we would
say that she exaggerated sore miss
specifies the causal power of
breastfeeding so harassment of women in
the workplace women who want to take
time off to pump for women who are
exposing their breasts in a closet now I
don't think that is the fault of
breastfeeding I think that's the fault
of sort of sexism and generally the
subordinate position of women in the
workplace more broadly I think that the
sort of victim the marginalization the
subjugation and the targeting of
african-american women is not the fault
of breastfeeding but is a response to
sort of pervasive racism and
breastfeeding is merely a vehicle to
further racism women leaving the
workforce is not the fault of
breastfeeding but it's another symptom
of you know pervasive gender inequality
and then even the kind of competition
judgement and shaming among women that I
have even you know admittedly been
guilty of I don't think that's the fault
of breastfeeding but rather
breastfeeding is just a vehicle to
express that kind of competitive
behavior and shaming um so the next sort
of ambivalence that I want to mention is
that especially in Courtney's critique
of the science there is a presumption or
a portrayal of parenting decisions as a
cost-benefit calculation well the
formula is sitting right there but if i
breastfeed now you know i'm gonna be 1/6
of my way toward one fewer ear infection
or i'm gonna be like half an IQ point
higher okay so and that's that's not the
way that i ever made any parenting
decisions I mean they were actually no
responding to a cost-benefit calculation
about the relative payoff of certain
types of behavior for me it was kind of
about instinct and survival the other
thing that I think there was an
ambivalence inand I didn't recognize
myself in some of the description of
people who breastfed is that I didn't
feel at least at the beginning like I
was breastfeeding to advance an agenda
such as to be green to be feminists to
oppose corporate control I felt like I
was breastfeeding because that's what my
baby wanted and needed now further on
down the road yes maybe I hooked it to
these other agendas but I think that
many people in the interstices of daily
life are not making cost-benefit
calculations they're not furthering an
agenda they're just they're just doing
so let me make I'm gonna wrap up in a
couple in a couple minutes here some
broader reflections I think the big
question that Courtney is addressing and
that the she calls it the moral fervor
but how about all of the discussion and
debate even that the book is provoking
hundreds of comments on the New York
Times web page you know lots of callers
into Brian Lehrer this morning lots of
action on Twitter even people responding
to my Facebook page you know why are so
many people um worked up about this now
Courtney does give us an answer she says
that people with diverse agendas have a
lot invested in breastfeeding and the
discussion is quite polarized breast
feed formula feed good parent bad parent
but what is largely absent in this
discourse are the voices of actual women
who are ambivalent who are you know
through trial and error their diverse
experiences their ambivalent experiences
their own I don't want to say suffering
but their own their own the the nature
and the the self understanding of the I
don't even want to call them choices
because choice sounds so rational but
the the instinctual behavior that
following when it comes to parenting I
think that if we actually listen to
these voices it would be hard for us to
degenerate into a polarized debate about
breastfeeding formula-feeding good
parent bad parent instead it would be
much more sort of richly complicated and
diverse and pluralistic so I think that
when we think about why there's a debate
at all and what the debate is like that
it's important that we see this as
another reflection of gender inequality
okay but women's voices often even in
this book are not the most prominent
ones when it comes to talking about
breastfeeding their male scientists
their male policymakers and that's a
reflection of a society that continues
to subjugate women all right if women
were actually speaking about
breastfeeding I think the debate would
be different um so just finally what
about gender equality anyway so um let
me just oppose sort of two visions or
two models of how to achieve it on the
one hand we have the kind of liberal
individualist choice model what Nancy
Fraser is now characterizing as
mainstream feminism but having it all
feminism that to be like successful to
be a fully realized woman who's having
it all we need to be CEO right or
president that we need to be fully
present in the public sphere like men
are kind of unburdened or unattached to
accessories and buy accessories I mean
sort of screaming children ties of
dependencies ailing parents etc now
formula-feeding is very conducive to
this type of feminism because it
presumes that I can you know outsource
or delegate care of my baby to somebody
who's going to feed it formula that's
one model an alternative model is one
that makes humanely ties of dependency
caregiving roles intimate human
relationships chaos complication
actually central to our normative
conception of the actor in the public
sphere of the politician of the CEO of
the worker and I think in this model the
public sphere is
defined by and includes breastfeeding in
fact I think breastfeeding is a good
teacher for this model it teaches us
that life is unpredictable that we can't
control things that it's messy and I
think therefore that and I believe in
breastfeeding is a mechanism to D
masculinize the public sphere but I am
grateful to Kourtney for teaching me
that it is not the only mechanism and
may not even be the best mechanism thank
you very much so we're going to take
questions in breastfeeding well the key
difference so the differences between
the United States and other advanced
Western democracies the BRIC the
differences in breastfeeding initiation
and duration are actually not all that
stark they you know one difference that
you could point to would be between the
United States and Canada in Canada you
have an 89 percent initiation rate in
the United States the initiation rate is
79 percent in the United States at six
months 49 percent of women are still
breastfeeding and in Canada 52 percent
of women are still breastfeeding so the
numbers are fairly comparable but the
huge difference between Canada in the
United States of course is that women
who women have maternity leave in Canada
and so women can they have they can make
a choice more freely about what works
for them because they have the time and
the space to breastfeed if they choose
to so the the although there are
breastfeeding advocacy programs and
projects in Canada they're not as
draconian as they are in the United
States it's not about withholding food
from people who don't
best feed it's you know it's just sort
of advertising in the subways or
something like that because instead they
have maternity leave and that maternity
leave does does make it a lot easier for
women to actually to wait for women to
be supported if in fact they do decide
to breastfeed and of course you know as
I'm sure you know the United States is
one of only four countries in the world
that has no federally mandated paid some
paid maternity leave and the others are
you know Swaziland and Papua New Guinea
and somewhere else so so I'm interested
in you talked about the research from
the pump companies and how that promoted
their way of thinking and the in terms
of natural breastfeeding but I'm curious
about any kind of research that is being
done on the formula side I mean was
Nestle so blown up by their 1950s you
know movement they just never got on the
bandwagon again with that it would seem
to me that this is all good conversation
but somebody on the other side would be
whoever we paid the millions of dollars
do to buy that formula stuff from that
they would they would actually promote a
research study of their own to you know
so well so they were partly completely
blown up by Nestle Nestle and Abbott and
all you know the other formula companies
they are not sponsoring Studies on
breastfeeding or infant feeding because
those studies would be roundly dismissed
you know people who are since my op-ed
was published in The New York Times a
number of people have written to me and
accused me of being being funded by
formula companies
you know the idea of being having
research funded by formula companies is
something that can't be done it's this
which is not to say that formula
companies aren't still making a lot of
money in the infant feeding sector you
know so if the breast pump industry is
2.6 billion dollars annually the formula
industry is seven billion dollars
annually
I expect that the breast pump the breast
pump industry is you know it's set to
take off its highest growth area of the
world is Asia it's looking it's it's
actively marketing aggressively
marketing in Asia and so you know it's
it's not 2.6 billion seven billion
dollars they're not completely there
there's a vast difference but it's not
completely apples and oranges the breast
pump market really is something so what
formula companies are doing now you know
they were definitely set back on their
heels by all of this advocacy around
breastfeeding and what they're doing now
is they're basically creating new
products for niche markets that they're
creating you know so it's follow-on
formula for when you wean as if there's
a particular food that your baby needs
for when it wins and there's formula
specifically geared for your
two-year-old and you know so they're
trying they're inventing all of these
new categories and they're selling
product in those categories and that's
how they're remaining competitive really
fascinating exchange
I've been read the book yet I heard you
on this morning and now now so I feel in
possession of a certain outline here but
I didn't hear it as small I heard it I
didn't think you were saying breast
feeding is the cause of all this
I saw it more as a symptom of the way in
which inequality is managed and you
could take it another 10 possible
instances of manipulation I just think
if there's an instance of how these
things are done
how you can I mean that women who were
forced to take to you is formula than
the women and we're forced not to you
know not to
I mean that the fact that these that the
story is very complicated and they've
been progressive moments for each side
and way right but that I think the
absence of women's voices has partly to
do with the fact that the story you're
telling us about you know the silencing
of that complexity and ambiguity I you
know I can imagine a feminist position
which obviously doesn't exist here that
it talks about you know the you know
better conditions for breastfeeding
although you know that maternity leave
the number of things you'd need in order
to make this work for you in the complex
life you have you know in which I think
you're gesturing towards right you know
how unequal women are is partly how
little the new virility they have um but
an interesting absence here and it's in
if it's in this your discussion and and
and also an in malice is if
breastfeeding is the key thing that's
you know in out up down the men
disappear men disappear from the
discussion it's fascinating to me you
know that people like Dorothy dinner
Stein and others who've written about
how inequality cannot be achieved
without men taking real you know central
fundamental charge of children along
with women and first of all lots of
feminists are ambivalent about that
think of how all the women who say oh he
can't do it you know only I can do it so
and you know this all this huge put new
number of places where people don't want
to hear about in relation to this this
is women's sphere Bivins power women's
bodies but I think you could easily
configure a feminist position that says
whatever one of these decisions you're
making uh-huh the issue would be are you
really sharing domestic work it's
inequality
is deeply embedded in the lack of
sharing of domestic work and in the
break between public and private space
mm-hmm so it's in a back to me is where
it happens how its reproduced right and
so I love your argument because I think
it it it shows the lack of leverage
about really changing the conditions
under which women do these things up and
down and just show you the weakness of
women's control over any of these
situations so I guess I agree with
malice final point which is inequality
is the core here you know one of my
students did a study of male breast
feeding you know what men have nipples
and he said they study that there were
men who had breastfed and you know the
women in the class got terribly upset
you know
here they are appropriating everything
and I was fascinated I mean I'm not
advocating that men should necessarily
take on breastfeeding but I do think men
should take on early care children and
that's a very fundamental feminist value
of mind so you know you this or you
could respond oh well I think yeah I
think that there's a good discussion so
let's gather a few points from the
audience and then she can respond I
might have something to say to my knees
very quick change my mind about my own
experience breastfeeding and I
appreciate it one of the things I didn't
see here in the New York Times the
article was the question about benefits
of breastfeeding not for the child but
argument about how it reduces the risk
of breast cancer and also I may help you
in like
postpartum depression and all of that so
I just want to hear thoughts on that
both the research and the argument
itself so I'm sorry I um thank you so
much for this
I thought the work was excellent the
books great I - just comments - maybe
for a discussion one was noting among
the group this scoffing notion at the
idea of masculine breastfeeding and it
kind of dovetails on utilizing
breastfeeding as a way to damask Yulin
eyes and I wonder if that is a
short-sighted goal one that is
inherently transphobic perhaps and kind
of keeps us in a very binary focused
trajectory for feminism and thinking
about the ways in which the trans
masculine body can be a pregnant body a
lactating body etc etc so opening that
up because I I think it's a it's a great
point and additionally that quick
distinction mala in your in your
commentary about are we utilizing
breastfeeding as are we kind of
conflating it as the problem as opposed
to a symptom or make merely it's an act
and I guess I'm wondering what everyone
thinks of is that possible though it's
like can you separate like the fleshy
bits out from the process so maybe it's
not actually that problematic to really
critique breastfeeding in the way it's
kind of picked up and held like it can't
be just a quote-unquote weapon to harm
women with or to judge women with if
it's literally part of the body so it's
kind of complicating that I guess Carmel
or was it carmella Renata who is next
Carmen wasn't it Carmel okay we're not -
Renata and Judith and then we'll come
back I'm supposed to be moderating so I
was sort of surprised man I was
expecting male to fight you on the
science but she didn't she told me at
lunch I couldn't Oh
because I guess I have to have a look at
the comments in The Times for a long
time so I don't know if that's where the
conversation is but I'm really surprised
that you're the Malaysian of these world
approved science has not at least today
cost I mean I don't maybe I'm just
trying to justify that I carry that
stupid pump for a year across town Oh
tell me there was something valuable
about doing that no besides really like
like so what Weiss I mean it's wh oh
it's like Universal so I can be just
evil agenda oh maybe it is just he will
end up but that and then I wanted to ask
you also the international question but
sort of because I think this is a very
good argument for the US definitely but
how does when you translate these to the
third world where people do not have the
money to buy the formula you know I
wonder if there is still a value on the
social on the public policy of just
supporting breastfeeding as so we don't
repeat all of the things that you
explained you know people actually using
dirty water you know there is other
conditions in which maybe this argument
will be different Judith
so you you are the one I also wanted to
go to the international question as well
and I was thinking Courtney and I share
an interest in Mexico where
breastfeeding is very is very dominant
in in rural areas and where in fact
diabetes is very high in the same room
and as I was thinking about comparative
research has anybody been looking at
that very fact I mean since one of the
you mentioned several times today that
one of the diseases that you're
preventing by having breast feeding
happens to be diabetes and you mentioned
and again I'm getting back to wanted to
hear on the basis of what are you
dismissing all
research I thought perhaps this was a
perfectly good example of why the
research may be problematic so I just
throw that out I think you want to
respond now and then we can take another
round after yeah I think I mean I a lot
of what people have said is not you know
not things I necessarily want to respond
to they're just interesting comments
good food for thought I do want to
respond to
Renata's question though because that's
that's a really it it's it is a puzzle
right what is the what's going on there
right so the fact is that there actually
is not a consensus among doctors about
the benefits of breastfeeding and so
it's it's presented as if there's a sort
of a hegemonic consensus on the benefits
of breastfeeding but just for example
since I wrote that op-ed in the New York
Times I have received many many emails
from doctors including you know from
family practitioners in Maine to former
Dean's of medical schools who have said
to me you're exactly right this is
exactly what the breastfeeding
literature shows and you're very brave
for pointing it out and you will be
accused of being funded by formula
companies and pediatricians I mentioned
this in my book you know pediatricians
in particular get demonized by lactation
consultants lactation consultants and
and in breastfeeding advocates always
say the pediatricians don't have the
right training and they just don't
understand how important breastfeeding
is and pediatricians on the other hand
say I am response
for the care of this one particular
child and they pediatricians are
actually quite quick to say you need to
move on from breastfeeding you need to
start feeding your baby formula because
your baby is failing to thrive you're
not producing enough breast milk etc etc
so doctors who are actually taking care
of patients in the real world have much
more ambivalent feelings about
breastfeeding than the public health
advocates who are making breastfeeding
policies now those public health
advocates here's where they're this is
what their position is their position is
those modest benefits that you get from
reducing the risk of infection are
actually important on a population wide
level so dr. David Mayer's the director
for the agency for Healthcare Research
and quality the AHRQ says if six women
breastfeed exclusively for six months
they will avert one ear infection that
one of those children otherwise would
have gotten as far as dr. David mares is
concerned that's great
that is a very powerful intervention but
he when when he read the op-ed in The
New York Times a reporter called him the
reporter said so what do you think about
this and he said this just makes my job
a whole lot harder because I didn't
quote those numbers for mothers to be
hearing that was what dr. I was that was
talking to doctors who understand what
that means as a public health initiative
or a public health intervention and his
position was what he said then was even
if the benefits are modest
why wouldn't we try to achieve them so
he's acknowledging that the benefits are
modest and saying why wouldn't we try to
achieve them and he said this and it's
out there in the public sphere now
because I read it in an article and what
he's doing when he's saying even if the
benefits are modest why wouldn't we try
to achieve them he's admitting that the
benefits are modest and he
not paying any attention at all to the
high costs that are being paid by trying
to achieve them
the very very high cost that mothers are
imposing on themselves and that we as a
society are imposing on mothers in order
to achieve these very very modest
benefits in reducing ear infections and
you know chances are you're not going to
reduce an ear infection that your own
child would have had you're reducing
someone else's you know eliminating
somebody else's ear infection which is
why I said you know I'm really sorry
about that year of pumping I could talk
about the international angle okay so
the last chapter of my book is about the
International dimension of this story
which of course is partly the Nestle
story you know it we're partly in the
1970s in poor countries around the world
and in those countries breastfeeding
advocacy is a still an important public
health project in those in many of those
countries formula-feeding is not
actually a safe alternative whereas in
the United States formula-feeding
is a safe alternative a very safe
alternative in in in a lot of poor
countries formula-feeding is not a safe
alternative but in the 1970s in the
early 1980s breastfeeding advocates were
were sort of took up this took up this
ideal and took up this project and and
international public health
organizations like the w-h-o and UNICEF
became convinced that breastfeeding was
the solution to many problems in
developing countries so they invested a
lot of money in breastfeeding advocacy
and support programs a very large
proportion of their funding was
reinvested into breastfeeding advocacy
and support and they hired a lot of
breastfeeding advocates and lactation
consultants in very important position
in the w8 show that was in the early
1980s they passed the code of marketing
there was the innocent II declaration
there are lots of things going on it was
like the heyday of international
breastfeeding advocacy in 1985 The
Lancet published the first evidence that
breastfeeding was that that HIV could be
transmitted through breastfeeding and
through breast milk in 1985 when The
Lancet published that information the
United States Canada New Zealand
Australia and all of Western Europe
immediately changed their infant feeding
guidelines to recommend that mothers who
were hiv-positive should feed their
babies formula and the w-h-o did not it
continued to recommend that all mothers
should breastfeed regardless of whether
they were HIV positive or not in 1992
don published a very important
meta-analysis that revealed not only
that breastfeeding was a transmitter of
HIV but in fact how large a transmitter
of HIV it was so as a result of Dunn's
meta-analysis people learned that up to
40% of babies who who are infected with
breast with HIV are infected through
breastfeeding right so 40% of the babies
who are infected with HIV are infected
with breastfeeding from 1985 when the
information was first revealed that the
when the information was first revealed
that HIV could be transmitted through
breast milk until 1998 the w-h-o
continued to recommend that all mothers
breastfeed regardless of their HIV
status and in 1998 as a result of
tremendous pressure and back pushback
from health ministers in poor countries
the w-h-o finally changed its infant
feeding guidelines recommended that
mothers who were who are age
be positive should feed their babies
formula and initiated huge programs in
poor countries they sent people in to
teach people how to use formula safely
they sent in formula they sent in a lot
of formula that was already mixed that
was already liquid formula and they
started giving away formula to mothers
who were HIV positive that was in 1998
then there's a whole backstory that has
to do with La Leche and AIDS denialists
we'll at which I will spare you right
now and we come to 2010 so tooth in 1998
this is an enormous setback for the
breastfeeding advocates who have been
fighting against this very transition in
infant feeding guidelines for 13 years
they've been fighting against this it
finally happens it's a big setback and
then they fight for the next 12 years to
get the guidelines changed again because
they are worried and they say this out
loud there they fear that HIV is a
threat to breastfeeding advocacy so the
threat of HIV is a threat to
breastfeeding advocacy I'm sorry I just
had to say that again so in 2010 the
w-h-o issued new infant feeding
guidelines and listen carefully to what
these infant feeding guidelines are in
countries where formula is safe and
affordable women who are hiv-positive
should be advised to feed their babies
formula when mothers have access to
antiretrovirals and their babies have
access to antiretrovirals women should
be advised to breastfeed because anti
retrovirals reduces the likelihood that
you will pass HIV to your baby now if
you the reason I said listen to this
closely as you will realize that bliss
leaves an enormous hole right in the
middle where of women who do not live in
countries where formula-feeding is a
safe alternative and
alternative and women who do not have
access to antiretrovirals right people
experts estimate that in South in Africa
in Africa as a whole 37 only 30% of 37
percent of pregnant women who are
hiv-positive have access to a RVs right
so 63% of hiv-positive pregnant women in
Africa they asked mate have no access to
a RVs what should those women be advised
to do the w-h-o now recommends since
2010 that if my mother is HIV positive
even if she has no access to
antiretrovirals she should be advised to
feed her baby right to breastfeed her
baby so there is this there's a huge
complication to the old story that we're
familiar with about the value of
breastfeeding in poor countries does
anybody have a question on this
particular topic on a different topic on
a different topic because I want to
address some of the previous topics but
that was just like that needed a pause
but I just wanted to briefly touch upon
Ann's question in your question whether
the extent to which equality depends on
sort of a reallocation of domestic
responsibilities and specifically on men
taking care of children so I know people
and I know people who you know firmly
uphold the idea of equality and equal
sharing and therefore and this also
fuels the breast pump industry and
therefore they do some pumping and they
make a point of you know having a bottle
and then the other parent you know the
non lactating parent will also feed
whether it's in the middle of the night
to give a break or during the day and so
forth
Courtney and I have shared a good laugh
together because we never did this you
know and I've been a committed feminist
you know virtually my entire life
but I've never I've never done that it
just seemed very contrived to me um
the easiest thing was to just you know
stick your breasts in the baby's mouth
and it will shut up and be calm right so
we we didn't do that but I know a lot of
people who do and and I think the
broader point for me anyway is that I
think having you know three children and
the sort of bodily experience of being
pregnant birth breastfeeding was a real
sort of challenge to me as sort of an
equal rights feminist and equality
feminist I mean it really sort of threw
me for a loop and caused me to kind of
reconsider or reconstruct my notion of
feminism I will say on a much more sort
of biological basis or rather and I
think that at that time I started
reading torille Moy and torille Moy sort
of brilliant book about what is a woman
right and she kind of teaches us I think
in that text that it's okay to embrace
biology and Badal eNOS without embracing
biological essentialism so that the body
you know doesn't have to determine your
lot in life or what you do with the body
but the body also doesn't need to be
denied either right it doesn't need to
be nine it doesn't need to jeopardize
sort of equal participation or equal
equal treatment now so so I have been
trying to construct and think of a
feminism that sort of incorporates the
unique the unique nature of the
reproductive functions of of the woman's
body including you know lactation and
therefore I'm really interested in kind
of reconstructing the public sphere
around what I think are universal values
of lactation potentially universal
values and I'm saying this to
incorporate I don't I don't think it it
may be trans exclusionary I don't think
it's transphobic and they may be the
same thing in your view okay um but to
reconstruct the public sphere around
what I think should be universally
revered and practiced values of sort of
you know biology dependency chaos attack
meant that I feel like you know has been
kind of the public's fear has been
alienated and sort of bled dry of those
types of practices what I need is one or
two satyr that have women's voices right
I think they'd be different opinion and
to me main taking very primary care
doesn't require breastfeeding or not at
all but not the boss but the point is
really that these discussions never what
egalitarian reorganization not only of
space you know and how you know who gets
to do what where and everything but also
of the life trajectory I mean why not
take a you know a year off and rest feed
and you know a man also talk about
paternally if you know that people get
different stages in life might really
need to withdraw from this the daily
grind and the discussion of pleasure is
so far away from the or displeasure so
far away from these you know the
analytical question and yet I think it
should be folded in so I don't want to
say choice because we know where that
leads us you know I choose to breastfeed
and I choose not to breastfeed you know
this is that horrible you know every
woman on her own you know no big social
changes but just a personal choice I
don't want to even use the word choice
but one would like there to be a range
of possible behaviors and support for
them one good thing about the La Leche
League is office they were just
horrendous their rhetoric was horrendous
it out I'm sure that's a funny part of
your book but one great thing about them
was they said nobody's helping women
mm-hmm you know that was that was a you
know I was a member
yes I mean I I used to think
they were the pronatal ISM was you know
like absolutely mad I thought the thing
about the Lachie league that was moving
was but it's it's part of what i hearing
right nice work is the coldness of the
manipulation and the embedded stuff that
you want and I don't think it's breast
feeding I don't think she's blaming
breasts for anything for all these
terrible things that are happening you
know of a kind of lack of elasticity in
what men do like that term Oh Todd three
two one it's basically in support of
your position and mostly that support
was coming from people who had felt put
upon the the activists so that speak
that's about to the huge the silent
majority who needed to be able to
discuss this I'm are you hoping for a
specific policy change to support these
people is they obviously need it well no
I'm hoping for I'm hoping for a policy
change that is maternity leave right but
that's not necessarily supporting the
women who are feeling put upon a policy
change like maternity leave would allow
women who want to breastfeed to do it in
a to actually breastfeed not to have to
pump breast milk so that somebody else
can feed their baby breast milk from a
bottle so that's the policy change that
I am interested in I'd also like WIC to
change its
policies I'd like to see the enhanced
food package eliminated and for that
sort of coercive mechanism of that
specifically geared toward inducing poor
people to choose breastfeeding I'd like
to see that eliminated but what I'm
really hoping for more fundamentally I
think and I think what a lot of those
women were saying that they they're not
necessarily experiencing that shaming
that's coming from from on top from
policy it's coming from everywhere it's
social and if we change the conversation
and we sort of start to look at what
we're actually doing and and also I
think if we look at it as something
that's actually bigger than the Mommy
Wars so I think that you know this this
has long been dismissed by identifying
it as an issue that is just about mommy
Wars and so I mean even calling it that
is very dismissive it's just sort of
what these mothers do because they're so
jealous and angry with one another if
you look at it as something that goes
far beyond the Mommy Wars that has all
of these larger implications and that is
that's that's insidious in these many
ways it'll change the conversation and a
lot of the my the way I read or heard a
lot of the comments that I've received
is this it's the conversation that needs
to change and that we're hoping that
your book will do some of that work in
changing the conversation any more
comments because there was a question
over there I really enjoyed I think it's
very eye-opening I think it's very
educational about this history I don't
yeah I can hardly hear you
okay so thank you so um you know I I
enjoyed your talk I thought it was
interesting and eye-opening I agree with
the points that you're making and I
don't
did I'd be saying anything with which
you would disagree if I were to say well
you know we know why things cash out
this way it's because of capitalism
right whether you breastfeed or the
bottle feed or formula feed or whatever
it's going to be majorly commercialized
because that is the capitalist world
live and likewise the reason why cashes
out in the ways that you're describing
is because of patriarchy right point of
patriarchy is that regardless of what
women do regardless of the choices they
make they're criticized for it they're
over managed in doing it you know etc
but the punchline of your book is not
Apple ism or patriarchy it's lack to
visit and I mean on the one hand I
understand why because it's 2015 and we
don't want to read books anymore that
say guess what it turns out the problem
is capitalism right good for you at this
point but there's kind of a problem with
that
and and let me draw an analogy is you
know we all know now that the
anti-vaxxer position is wrong right we
know that those people have no medical
AB we know that what they're doing is
socially irresponsible because it's not
contributing to herd immunity and you
know if you if any of you are on the
internet I'm sure you've noticed over
the last couple years that it's like a
pastime on you know Twitter Facebook
whatever especially among the left you
just castigate these anti-vaxxer like
these idiot and these like socially
irresponsible morons
I had a friend point out to me that like
there's there's a problem with that and
the problem with that is the reason why
people were attracted to the anti-vaxxer
position which in my memory dates to
like around the 90s maybe it was earlier
than that they didn't just have to do
with the fear of autism and that one
doctor guy who has been discredited the
reason why people were attracted to it
and in attachment parenting circles and
whatever is because you know the moment
that you get pregnant you're introduced
to this medical system and the social
system and social services delivery
system and you know informal pressure
that is incredibly condescending
contradictory judgmental and and
invalidates all of the choices that you
make and forces upon you all kinds of
unnecessary
forms of intervention and monitoring and
so on and so forth
and you can understand why people turned
to an anti vaccination physician why
some mothers for example turn to an anti
vaccination position because they were
tired of these unnecessary interventions
they were trying to use their own
judgment and in their judgment that
seemed the best for their child and so
when we very easily and snidely
denigrate that